go yeah welcome back to the gentleman
Jojo well comedian steve byrne Gary
cannon we are here fresh from the road
touring all that stuff thank you guys
for coming out to the show's Thanks for
seeing us yeah thanks for holding my
feet when I do sit ups thanks for
counting me off thanks for being my
inspiration thank you to the Lord above
thank you god bless america here we are
you're trying to get to fit on the road
now you're trying to a watch G I'm
trying to watch what I eat it's
difficult because I I have the worst
diet in the world literally yeah but you
don't wait on you don't look like yeah
yeah you get bigger I look like you here
we go i'm trying to start a nice
conversation that's my new mantra for
the end of this year and here we go
honestly when you take your shirt off
and you look you look at yourself in the
mirror before you take a shower what do
you think well i'm not happy haha i do
it's been a long time second i ask you
what's what is the last time you look at
yourself naked in the mirror before you
took a shower or what does last time
young yeah yeah you looked at yourself
you go now that's a bo Derek better that
when's the last time you felt good about
yourself good about a fella legacy uh
maybe hmm hey are you serious no I don't
know what is the last time honestly well
I know it's been a long time I mean I've
had man boobs for a little while but you
have tits yeah you've seen him we've
shared a room together do you remember
yeah I don't look at you I try to
visually block it out we have to share a
room because you can't sell tickets on
the route here we know but it's part of
your star did you get it did you get a
room this weekend I shared it with our
guest today uh you have your own bedroom
I know here we go now referred you have
your own bedroom I did wasn't a two
bedroom suite it was a two bedroom there
you go with a two bedroom suite go [ __ ]
and by the way I picked up your
incidentals no [ __ ] you picked up
or incidentals [ __ ] I looked at the
bill there was more of yours no you put
so let get anything let's it was forty
dollars when I cashed out was that wrong
I I so here's what happened for
everybody listening those three people
what I did was I we were we were going
into the lobby of the residence inn
marriott and I grabbed a bottle of water
and I said put it on room 116 which is
my room and you got mad right I could
tell you were being a big baby Huey oh
baby Huey I was like yo just put on in a
room why would you put a water on my
right a car down a file on my room they
never asked for one so I put it on your
room right can see were being a big old
baby Huey about it so then what I did
was at the end of the the weekend when I
was leaving for the airport i just paid
it it was like forty dollars i was like
like a dry cleaning done yeah i saw that
on there that was like eight bucks yeah
i paid for the whole [ __ ] thing no
you bought stouffer's french bread
pizzas you bought like water you got
chips every day you walk back in that's
all yours I didn't get anything I didn't
put anything on my room well the dry
cleaning eight dollars so i owe you
eight dollars right I'll take it yeah
course you where you spend it on juicy
fruit and starbursts you've got [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] off um well it's good
to see you great to see you always it's
nobody people people people have said to
us when we tour the road together people
have said are you guys really friends on
the road or you guys do you guys really
like each other when we do the show when
we are on this podcast or but we do we
do like each other well sort of yeah I
mean it's friends it's a dicey
proposition yeah but yeah I guess
friends is a acquaintances yeah yeah
business partners the partners no
business partners out there that means
we're 5050 that means like if I do an
hour of material you would do an hour of
material but you do you sweat it like 20
well there's been no you yeah well
that's why I like I said when I ever do
the longer sets I encourage gesetz I'm
all about all right we have a caller we
don't to see if this is uh hello oh well
this is starting out great oh hello yeah
how are you well good was it is punched
out
uh yes did this is not punch drunk my
friend ho co this is the gentleman's
dojo who's this who's this mud what's
your name I think are awesome and what
did you want to ask punch punch drunk is
a great call did you have a question for
punch drunk well this isn't puncher the
[ __ ] is the dojo what is this [ __ ] yeah
it's called the gentleman's dojo yeah
Gary cannon steve byrne it's number one
on iTunes yep it's the greatest podcast
ever yeah what what what is yo through
for punch drunk cuz maybe we can help
you out sweet no no man well should I
wanted to talk about the courts but what
is this about it's about being a man
it's about taking an axe into the woods
and yep splitting wood with an axe like
old school like rocky or fixing [ __ ]
yeah yeah doing [ __ ] man [ __ ] yeah you
have a question for two men yeah what he
got throw it out there you want to talk
about your man [ __ ] a man will do it
you jerking it right now hell no girl
wants to have a [ __ ] threesome are
you down one having sex you do to the
same time yeah but actually that that
actually just came in my way but i'm not
i'm not really into that [ __ ] I hear you
man just you know if you're gonna have
that three-way just tell us about your
dick like what you work with is it veiny
is it long as it yeah robbing is it a
two-hander and [ __ ] we talk is it like a
sign find it the two-hander it's a
[ __ ] you know I mean very nice not
[ __ ] technique but I know how to work
the [ __ ] that's right on let me
lay down and point my toes tell me more
about that dong this episode not gonna
make this is awful all right we really
appreciate you calling in man do you
have they have our do you have an honest
question for two standard comedians or
that are on a podcast that you have no
idea who you called into dude I have no
[ __ ] idea who you guys called it you
guys sound funny as hell dude what's
your guys's podcast name it's called
drunk yes I said skull the gentleman's
dojo but um gentlemen the gentleman's
dodo yes be burning Gary cannon arm
people oh [ __ ]
Aaron all right yeah yeah yeah I've
heard about you man you a swear to God I
got this [ __ ] number you guys have a
punch-drunk is right oh yeah of course
yeah it's a great podcast I think
they're on in an hour I believe in at
noon so you call back there at noon you
could talk to them and we wish all the
best ones you gotta do the same number
that what's going on yeah it's the same
studio I know [ __ ] [ __ ] how much acre
plot gets out man all-father you take
that third leg you take that third leg
and you be proud cuz i'm calling from
protective suits with my x all [ __ ] up
ok but I done while the best yard you
guys felt funny as hell man for sure
keep it real Texas thanks pal later
brother jacket for me baby ok Gary no
sorry absolutely disco well well this
one sir that was uh yeah that was her
first caller oh that were somebody
called in life that was our first caller
and it was not for us I know I'll take
that I'll take it he was intrigued
though that was pretty funny sound like
yeah you guys got a good vibe there in
the dojo do this alright so here's what
we're talking about today Oh God ok we
actually do have a caller you want a
patch man hey oh wow what it what an
exciting kind of vibe you brought to the
table all right did you just wait him up
eating already on hi Gareth hey I could
be way more excited you're so ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the gentleman's
dojo mr. Gareth Reynolds of the dollop
podcast and he quite often goes on the
road with us and Gareth and I met each
other years ago in Las Vegas we were
cast in the Ashton Kutcher show the real
wedding crashers which was basically
Punk'd but for weddings and well you
probably don't need to tell people that
they probably already know where we met
because that show was such a huge hit
huge huge hit massive not even am I am I
am I crazy or did they turn that show
into a movie eventually oh yeah with uh
I know you get their names but a cup a
couple guys I think turned it into a
mood I don't remember so many franchise
well tell you this about that show when
when that show aired when it premiered
it was an hour long show I think it
aired like on a thursday at eight
o'clock I was with my parents
and I think I told you this story but my
dad and mom we sat down we watched were
watching NBC I'm on the show 40 minutes
goes by my parents don't talk to me I
don't say anything and at the 40-minute
mark they're here the commercial my dad
just looks amigos what the [ __ ] is this
was like oh we're doomed all were doomed
that was pretty rough by the way that
was the nicest thing a critic it said
about it what the [ __ ] is this um that
was what he's most proud of now Gareth
you had the wonderful experience of
being on the road with us quite often
quite a bit um just so we can get the
wheels greased in terms of what our
subject matter will be today do you want
to express to the folks what your
experience has been thus far in terms of
working with Steve burning Gary cannon
on the road what has been your
experience so far uh you know I mean you
you you're very lucky when you get to go
on the road for the guy like Steve
because not only is a great comic is a
very giving individual and you know just
being able to watch and perform I think
makes you a better stand up and here's a
piece of [ __ ] here Gareth obviously has
an empty calendar and he needs more
dates so you suck you off Jesus Christ I
completely disagree I have a great gig
in town I don't need these [ __ ] gigs and
I'll tell you how it really is Steve's a
piece of [ __ ] he's cheap I had to pay
for all of his [ __ ] incidentals at
the residence inn because he was being a
big [ __ ] because I put one water he had
dry cleaning on it any time we go out
and paid for breakfast on Saturday I
don't need the [ __ ] gigs and if you want
to keep no last know the funny bone
Wayne to everybody why you had to pay
for breakfast you [ __ ] why did you
have to pay for breakfast I guess so we
go to Old Town Sacramento which is a
very oh it's a touristy area or of a
tons of great little restaurants were
thinking let's go explore see the sights
we go there and little piggies not happy
cuz piggy wants brunch so what we have
to do Gary well I suggested a local
place that I need not before in
Sacramento called the tower cafe yeah so
we take an uber there which I pay for
right and right we get there there's a
12 minute wait 12 minute wait yes you
Gareth how long was the wait Twilight
[ __ ] off 20
wait a minute wait eight minutes that
you'd have time for 20 20 minutes alive
so what would you have to do i do wait
as long as I had to do did you have 20
minutes I don't know what's more sushi
ating waiting 20 minutes to eat or watch
interact for 20 minutes cuz that's where
you tie I think that this this is pretty
much summed up what it's like to be on
the road with you guys this conversation
yeah it is right yeah yes it's this it's
this over and over again and it's great
and i'm not i'm not against it at all no
boy garrett did you see your check at
the end of the week how [ __ ]
disgusting um you obviously got your
tire / you got [ __ ] over twice this
weekend what happened with your tire uh
they they slashed a bunch of tires in my
neighborhood 30 36 cars got their tires
flattened really so we're all just going
out celebrating right you know the fun
morning it's been great it's a great way
to wake up now do they know who the
culprit is or no now the good news is
nobody knows anything and everyone says
that it's gang affiliated about it but I
will say what a kind of loser game like
you know I feel like that's kind of a
gang nobody would really care about well
I want a gang were you like you know you
have to beat the [ __ ] out of a stranger
like Fight Club it did not go down
slashing a tire on it 92 civic that's
great well they probably worked up
together cars are like probably walked
up to Gary's car they're like [ __ ] this
one's been tagged already look at this
piece of [ __ ] somebody already somebody
already keep this [ __ ] so my best of
the bunch leaders have no limit they
actually saw Gary's car the like let's
put five bucks in an outdoor we feel bad
for this guy they put a new tire on it
yes that he doubled his money from
Sacramento uh-oh here we go Gareth we
were thinking that maybe we could
discuss our favorite food spots on the
road you couldn't be a worse guy to have
on for the segment oh yeah this is a
terrible segment for me to be a part of
me because you
you out of everybody you hate eating
with me more than anybody even Garrett
well I hate eating with Gary cuz i know
i gotta pay for it but I hate meeting
with you because you are it [ __ ] yeah
yeah I'm glad I [ __ ] up your tire last
night but you're a vegetarian yeah when
did you make the transition maybe this
what we're we're gonna talk about our
favorite food spots but how the [ __ ] are
you a vegetarian talk about how big of a
[ __ ] I am instead space uh I uh I think
I stopped eating meat about four years
ago but I always kind of been like uh
not super into eating meat but I really
I gave it up for years ago uh you know
for for many reasons but uh but you're a
guy you're going to talk about your
you're from the midwest you're from
Wisconsin how do you not enjoy a good
steak III don't understand how can you
not like go to roost Christian see that
steak come out that's bubbling with the
butter and about how do you are you not
like yeah I want to [ __ ] that up at you
this is a conversation we literally have
that probably every meal where yo yo
hold up you'll like what you look at
what you're eating that is me and you
look at me like kind of disgusted like a
lettuce crisp do that yeah how do you
get excited about a lettuce crisp when
you see like a give chance they bring
out the lettuce Chris and you're like no
chicken I just want more lettuce in the
lettuce course this is great are you get
bombed about that butter when that
lettuce was bubbling with that butter
come on out of here I mean do you not
miss like a Juicy's when you go to a BBQ
are not like dr. their place there's a
place near where I live which is Compton
um there's a place near where I live
that i'll drive by this kind of like an
outdoor barbecue place and i'll drive by
there and you know there are familiar
smells but I'm like oh I remember I
remember some good times but the truth
is that you know like living in LA it's
a lot easier to be a vegetarian you see
me out on the road what I like the
options are like salads and french fries
basically so that's basically what my
diet so throwed my doctors over the moon
about it I mean are you healthier now
I'm much healthier yeah yeah i wasn't i
think show that there's there's ways
there's ways to be like an unhealthy
vegetarian which is just you know a lot
of fried [ __ ] but no I eat a lot of like
vegetables and stuff like that how do
you approach anything I get protein from
like protein shakes and then I also you
know there's protein in a lot of
vegetables and I still eat eggs you know
I'm not vegan so or comic the one thing
he said over a comic I I literally can't
wrap my head around it like I get it if
you wanna eat a salad here therefore
meal how do you not want to have a hot
dog at a ballpark like Ronnie I just
can't get my head around night you know
I mean the truth is you not what about a
hot dog at a ballpark no there's but the
truth is a hot dog you know the hot dog
of the ballpark I mean you know you do
your bit about McDonald's you don't mind
food that has weird like slimes in it
and stuff I just AM like I you know hot
dogs to me are really gross like what
they are made out of and you know and
I'm like I i am very Pro animal so I
don't eat it because of that [ __ ] that
or not yeah that's why don't want to
talk about so you you feel that like
killing a chicken is wrong I feel I feel
like factory farming is wrong which is
where most of the meat comes from yeah
but look like what are you supposed to I
supposed to feed a population people
well there's only humans farther uh well
there's what you I mean I think part of
the thing in new number this is a really
fun who's gonna be really funny
interview part of it part of the thing I
think is that you know you really people
are so conditioned to having to have
meal meet with every single meal and
it's you know it's not like that
everywhere if you think about like
global warming stuff I mean that's the
worst thing about that is how far Gareth
Oh what Gareth core I don't want you
were going to talk about places being on
the road I'm
I wanted to I wanted to but then I
talked to the the wilting the wilting
flower that is global global war we were
going to talk about comedy other place
either other we got a call from art and
then he started beating off on the phone
and then at this point I have to ask you
so yes so when is the last time you had
a steak so actually the last time that I
had a steak was with you [ __ ]
because we I had just sort of said to
myself like okay I'm done and then um we
I was probably at day 5 and you me and
you know pie seven other people went to
Vegas for the weekend and we were at
like a steak house and I you know
everyone's ordering and chatting and I'm
like two seats away from you and I just
sort of whisper to the later like I'll
just take like us some sashimi because i
was getting fish that I was like I'll
take some sashimi in a salad you in the
middle of a conversation look over and
you go I'll [ __ ] now you're having at
stake your level I'm Abbott and I'm like
well no I'd rather you go yeah we're to
fake out so I go okay and then we ate to
say did I know you were vegetarian then
I don't think I knew you were vegetarian
know then that after the steak you go
that wasn't very good but how do you go
to steak house and not have a steak I
don't understand it I do you not let me
not want ribs you know it really like I
think like anything else I think if you
get conditions to the point like yeah
add answer to your question is sort of
yeah you know you don't want right yeah
but there's there's other things that I
enjoy eating that aren't you know that
aren't meet that I'm able to do you can
enjoy you don't really do enjoy I don't
eat fish how do you any fish here's the
surface of people nice to meet
pescetarian czar the weirdest people
because it's like if you're not going to
eat things that are alive then what are
because fish are like scaly people like
oh [ __ ] fish I'll really yeah so if if
like a lettuce if it let us cried would
you not eat it when you when you pulled
it from from the ground when you
uprooted it give me me me me me me yeah
yeah yeah people like people like
domesticated lettuce and we're taking
lettuce for walks and like you know too
let us to like the lettuce part to play
with other lettuce I prob initiation
okay if there's an apocalyptic event if
something awful happens yet needed a red
line but are you just gonna sit there
pick berries are you gonna go I'm gonna
but I'm probably to eat other people I
mean I'll eat anything if there's the
apocalypse all that's wrong then I don't
care about anything but me so you're
looking for Gary cuz you're like well
I'm gonna be well fed from least a few
weeks oh dude that'll be there like a
rib but they load on the flint rock yeah
with a slashed tire in fairness though
you get condition you gotta move my car
like he gets ka is you just you're used
to it now because you've been doing it
for so many years it's like when Steve
walks into a comedy club there's nobody
there you're used to it that's exactly
what here we go you're used to just dead
crowds nobody being there you're used to
it it's like when you go home and you
see a past due pass to pass to india in
in your mailbox for the bills yeah
nothing Gareth let me ask you something
you're obviously kiss and Steve's asks
to get more dates you obviously have a
date yet um thank you Gary what's your
what's your favorite uh funny bone to do
with Steve which which what's your
favorite sea level when he's setting you
up don't fall for this because he's good
you know Garrett's gonna answer
something then you're gonna just not
topple him down no okay God as I see
Gary smiling God God I like Cleveland
why Gary cleveland oh that's what which
club is that the improv now that is
funny but isn't it no he this guy
doesn't [ __ ] work um okay great um
tell us about what you got coming up so
we can start wrapping this [ __ ] up okay
right your can I say Gary you are an
unbelievable interviewer you really
thank you you're very good I'm be Tom
Lycus of podcasting awful it really are
can I ask you as a vegetarian what is
like if I'd I can't even believe it like
anytime we order picture if you like a
sausage pepperoni than that the other
haps plane for Gareth Bale look you're
lucky I still do sausage party with my
beliefs yeah that's true that is true is
there one thing though you do miss
though like like if you
Pass McDonald you not like I [ __ ] up a
big mac no it was never I i even when
i'm the only time when I ate a lot of
fast food will was when I was really
broke so last week right Gary go ahead
I'll do it I that that's really the only
time that I ate a lot of fast food I I
always liked the thing i can always
liked it i just like chicken so I would
you know like fried chicken is the thing
that every now and then actually one
time when I was uh I was basically off
me I did either is like 10 years ago but
someone a Kentucky Fried Chicken I was
like ham appease that [ __ ] [ __ ] oh man
but yeah I mean really you know yeah it
was it was that and the truth is you you
know like I said I mean you do this you
do miss that stuff but la is like just
full of places that make things like
like when we get real food day with be
at the airport like you admit that that
is a good it was a good sandwich but i
will say that great family in the great
family when I am healthy I feel like all
I'm being sober is any sense like now
I'm I'm sober and I know this is good
for me but it's like I i wanna go I want
to be bad alchemy app app I want to eat
a pizza yeah here I want gravy fries
don't want either of em I and I think
you hold I think when we go out to eat
and you eat a salad you get mad at me
for your decision oh [ __ ] here we go do
you not feel that your quote-unquote
like being sober as a vegetarian or you
just like no this is I just don't want I
don't want anybody kill cows no I I mean
look it's it's in a way it is like that
I guess except uh yeah I mean it's it
just isn't as hard for me as I think it
is for you I mean there's you know
obviously different I for me the hardest
part was when I had to like go back to
Wisconsin and tell my friends and it was
kind of like coming out of the closet to
a lot of them um you know that I had not
eat that I was done eating me but now
that's the point where I'm so like you
know it it really doesn't it really
doesn't even factor into my my thinking
anymore unless i'm at like chilis in the
bumble [ __ ] and I'm like a good don't
those guys have a reaction like I do
though where you just say are you
kidding me Steve all I will say I think
your reaction is
stronger yes I think I think you're the
most perturbed by it Gareth how many
pair of a lululemon stretchy pants how
many pay lululemon stretchy pants hey
don't you do you do yoga don't you you
know this interviews oh why don't you do
yoga do you not i I do do yoga holy [ __ ]
you're turning into a divorced woman I
don't know who you are anymore I like
also I like white wine oh my god maybe
that our credit will start bringing in
people sorry I listen I understood him
I'm a man from Wisconsin with a Packard
tattoo who does yoga and doesn't eat
meat it's not easy that's five yet crazy
to me I came over friends with you we
should get him in touch with that to
pick up artist yeah he can help Wow
Gareth um just a true wow yeah I don't
know what yeah I like really like it
like angers me that you I don't know why
I but I seriously can I get everyone
picked up i I don't understand it I mean
I don't understand how you can't like
see like a bone-in ribeye and be like oh
god [ __ ] that up yeah I want to tear
that up what ya or leash of the buyer s
saying take that bone Gary like korean
BBQ you wouldn't smell a korean BBQ and
go oh man i would love to eat that right
now here's the thing Steve you can you
can put whatever kind of neat I'm never
kind of verse of me on if you want i'm
not going to eat it I can't stand you
you you feel like you're gonna find this
silver bullet that I'm gonna be like oh
[ __ ] yeah I'll eat that but I what is
one thing you crave like if I want a
steak like if I reward myself it's like
Saturday sold-out shows bonuses a line
around the block [ __ ] off Gary no way i
reward myself I go I'm getting a bone in
14 ounce of filet mignon at ruth's chris
or something what is your thing what's
like your dream there it
you I don't I just don't I don't I'm not
that crap you love food right what is
your what is your reward though what is
what is one meal you have we like I
gotta reward myself with a fairness with
a Cobb salad I don't know is there a
reward though in fairness divas not hey
time again you will let me add Gary
question in fairy has not had that steak
in almost 14 years [ __ ] off yeah God
Gareth what's your question Carrie
Carrie yes Gary there no I'm in the
parking lot okay let the other night
we're in Steve's room yes was about to
order dominos them like a tacoma or
something he's about to order dominoes
and he's looking it up on his computer
and as he looking it up to itself he
goes mm-hmm and he was humming food
glorious food to himself oh my god but I
was doing here like for real i wasn't
even it was like subconscious and again
those are you humming food glorious food
I'm like yeah yeah I am I was so happy
yeah I mean and that's the difference
like Steve will walk around like with
the mentality of an orphan is about to
get some pork like I was just like yaoi
dominoes whatever's he was just like oh
man we've been living on gruel all day
finally well I should look like John
Candy but of all people should look like
John Candy yeah and by the way the
ordering pizza with steve is the worst
who will get one small for eight guys
eight [ __ ] adults oh well you can go
[ __ ] your [ __ ] fat cells we have
enough pizza for everybody yeah we
didn't know we did set pieces yeah there
were two pieces left no everybody grab
it I'll sure you didn't sleep with that
under your pillow Gareth thank you so
much for calling in I was a real we love
you I hope you enjoy you know that whole
foods yeah sliced cucumber whatever the
[ __ ] you e yeah thank you buddy thanks
guys thank you guys thanks for being so
sweet oh thank you to give basket to be
in denial all right buddy I but um all
right you want to go ahead with the uh
oh yeah yeah let's do this right yeah
little giveaway right sure all right
well on surprise then you could tell
people what caller to be okay sure we're
in the travel season my friend the
holiday season I'm very excited my
favorite
the year so uh the fine people of
southwest airlines have given us a
three-hundred-dollar gift card whoa for
travel with that is a round trip right
there united states which would expire a
year from now so what color should they
be mr. Byrne ah let's say eight eight
eight so let's do the amount of people
that were at your last show aight well i
think the archers coordinate let ya or
call early phrase that phrase Hayes
Southwest Airlines thank you guys for
your support of our show we appreciate
it well that concludes this episode of
the dojo we got to thank our vegetarian
/ I can't believe in friends with him
Gareth Reynolds yes he's on a great
podcast called the dollop they take
these obscure moments in history and
talk about them and it's truly
fascinating and I think they're gaining
a lot of steam they just did a tour of
Australia ah here we are at the
conclusion of ours Gary where can they
find you a canon comedy yes yeah
everything online canon comedy i am
everything at steve byrne live guys New
Year's Eve Pittsburgh improv come on out
to the show's Chicago februari sixth I
will be taping my fourth hour special at
lincoln hall to show 7 and 10 p.m. gary
will be with me he'll be opening the
shows we cannot thank you guys enough
guys keep the reviews coming in we
appreciate those iTunes keep up the
questions coming in if you have any
suggestions any questions anything for
us let us know we are down to make you
part of the podcast all these comedy
thanks for the support everybody